we're going to begin this hour with
Senator Bernie Sanders of Vermont and
Senator first of all welcome second of
all your visit comes on a day we've got
some breaking news some genuine breaking
news from Keith where President Biden
met with Ukrainian president zielinski
this morning it was Mr Biden's first
visit to Ukraine since the Russian
invasion nearly a year ago and this week
also Senator Sanders is out with a new
book it's called it's okay to be angry
about capitalism Senator good morning to
you because of the Ukraine news before
we get to the book I want to ask about
the situation in Ukraine we're sending a
lot of money there at the moment money
generated by our capitalist system so
there is a connection I suppose what
needs to happen going forward with U.S
policy toward you well I'm glad the
president is in Ukraine
what Putin did is outrageous it is the
worst conflict in Europe since World War
II and I think it is important for the
United States NATO our allies to tell
Putin he's not going to be able to get
away with it and uh I support with the
president is doing we support what the
president is doing all right let's talk
about the book it's okay to be angry
about capitalism
why did you think now was the time for
this message and why okay it seems like
you you feel that there's a degree of
resistance to the idea of any criticism
look Tony this country faces enormous
crises and it's important that we have a
serious discussion about those crises
economically what's going on in America
simple reality is the people on top the
billionaire class are doing phenomenally
well meanwhile the middle class
continues to shrink and in the richest
country in the history of the world
today over 60 percent of the American
people are living paycheck to paycheck
virtually every city in this country has
a major housing crisis we are the only
major country on Earth not to guarantee
a health care to all people as a human
right we spend twice as much per capita
meanwhile drug companies making billions
the insurance companies making billions
the gap between the rich and everybody
else growing wider we don't talk about
those issues let's lay it out on the
table let's have that talk about those
issues you lay them out very well here
in the book and you say things that we
had heard from you on the campaign Trail
many years ago but I think what the
American people struggle with is how do
you change a system that appears to be
broken in so many ways well let's put it
that's again that's a good question and
the answer is this system is working
very very well
for the people who own this network for
the billionaire class we are involved in
class Warfare people on top are doing
great so it's not hard to come up with
the idea you want health care for all
the every major country on earth is
doing I live 50 miles away from Canada
you have leukemia you're in the hospital
for a month you know what your bill is
when you get out zero as a nation is
spending half what we spend per capita
so you look at taxing billionaires for
an example but what other Solutions are
you are you off in terms of health care
look just think for a moment if
everybody in America today said you know
what when I'm sick my kid is sick I go
to the doctor I don't have to worry
about the bill all right you know what
that would mean to the health of this
country if people did not have to worry
about sending their kids to college and
what it would cost them if people didn't
see their housing cost cut we are the
richest country in history well we
should be discussing this why don't we
have health care for all why isn't
college education at least public
colleges and universities tuition free
why do we have a gap do you think does
anybody think America three people are
more wealth in the bottom half of
American society anyone think that's
appropriate let's talk about it what do
we do about it you're saying that the
system is working the way it's intended
to work exactly it's working great for
the billionaire class no doubt about it
now you introduced a bill last week with
Senator Warren that would not only
extend Social Security but increase
benefits now do you believe that by
taxing wealthier Americans that you
could get some bipartisan support on
this bill we'll see uh but what it
when we talk about the problems of
America and why we're not solving them
please don't forget that this political
system is corrupt as well all right so
if you are a member of Congress right
and you will put into Power by some
Super PAC owned by a billionaire you
think the first thing you're going to do
is say I think billionaires should pay
their fair share of taxes I doubt it so
you got a corrupt political system I
know that sounds harsh
but if super Pacs can spend unlimited
months of money sums of money to beat
you right is that corrupt what I think
it is one of your proposals in here is
actually to rewrite parts of the
Constitution to make changes but I you
know the guy at home right now even the
guy you're not doing well sitting at
home might be saying yeah but you're
acknowledging that this system we have
has created more wealth than any country
has ever had in the history of the world
tremendous Innovation things you
acknowledge in the book and now you're
talking about changing that I get you
know or tweaking it Tony it is created
enormous wealth for the people on top
you tell me in this great nation
I grew up in a family that struggled
economically we lived paycheck to
paycheck why today in 2023 over 60
percent of the people living paycheck to
paycheck why let's talk about where we
want to go and I'll tell you something
else that's happening with all of the
artificial intelligence the Robotics are
out there who's making those decisions
whether you're going to have a job or
not have a job are working people
involved that so all that I'm saying in
this book in that this age with all of
the technology out there all the wisdom
out there let's create an economy that
works for all not just a few I want to
ask a question about Jimmy Carter here
uh but you know on AI it is current tax
policy in this country that if companies
uh buy an AI system it's a capital
investment even if it lays off workers
they get a tax benefit you're encouraged
by the system I imagine you would want
to change that but we would say in tax
robots that's right that's exactly right
yeah uh Jimmy Carter uh just a core of
decency and modesty didn't serve on
corporate boards went back to his
hometown didn't go to live in some giant
mansion didn't give high-powered
speeches worth a lot of money uh regular
guy not a quote normal guy seems like a
regular guy uh in in real life your most
memorable uh encounter with him if you
could sir uh I everything you said is
true I mean uh he was a good president I
think but people will remember him for
is what he did after the presidency he
didn't capitalize on being president you
got a lot of boys you can make a whole
lot of money I think he still lives
today in the home that he grew up in
Plains Georgia I had the opportunity to
meet him several times he is a decency
is the word he is a very his family is
very decent down to earth ordinary uh
people uh I was with him a number of
years ago at the Carter Center which was
really really good work among other
things making sure that elections held
around the world are done democratically
and fairly so he has lived out his
post-presidential years with a lot of
dignity we should all be proud of what
he is accomplishing all right Senator
Sanders I see your wife Jane over there
did you give her a text or anything on
Valentine's Day just uh I have no
comment on that actually it's classified
I'm gonna try to catch Jane's eye over
there we'll talk about that in the break
uh Senator Center thank you very much
appreciate you being here the book is
it's okay to be angry about capitalism
and it goes on sale tomorrow and you can
see more of Senator Sanders tonight on
The Late Show with Stephen Colbert that
would be a very good conversation oh
that's gonna be good I'm gonna tune in
for that